hello everyone my name is kiran kumar
today along with my co-author shivan
kirk
we will present our recent work titled a
model for hand trail formation
this is in joint work with professor
moses tariqah
and professor debrian gordon
moses and myself are computer scientists
and deborah is a biologist who is an
expert in hands
this this work started trying to explain
some of the field observations debra
made about turtle lands
let me start with a high level theme
that motivates our work
we humans initiated the formal study of
computation
over the past century while nature has
been designing algorithms
for past 3.5 billion years
there are many examples illustrating
this
the most obvious and the most tracking
example
is the brain another interesting example
is the slime world
in a fascinating experiment nakagaki
at all in 2000 in 2000
they observed that sly mold can solve
the shortest path
problem in a maze
in their experiment they covered the
maze with slime mold
they fed the slime with oatmeal at the
two end points of the maze
after few hours they observed that the
slime converts to the shortest path
between the two endpoints which is quite
fascinating
along these lines another such example
is bird flocking
researchers here try to understand how a
flock of birds fly together
in a particular direction and change
direction just using local
communications
there are many more such biological
systems which are quite interesting
and there has been a huge amount of work
on these biological systems
the citations provided here are far from
conflict
this computational view of biological
systems
serves two main purposes first
it provides a fresh perspective for
understanding the world around us
second it provides new algorithmic
insights
because of the unique constraints faced
by nature
our work started because of the
surprising observation made about
turtlenecks
these ants nests and forages on trees
the trail network of these hands is
constrained to lie
on the graph formed by tangled branches
and whites
some of these turtle lines can be seen
in the picture
in particular we study turtle ants
specifically cephalot's goniotas
as discussed before these ants for these
ants form
trail network on graph formed by tangled
branches and points
these networks connects several nests
and food sources and they extend
hundreds of meters
spans many trees
these ants lay pheromone as they move
along
and this pheromone guides their choice
of edges to traverse
here is a picture that illustrates
the atypical trail network formed by
triangle branches
now coming back to the surprising
observation about internets
chandrasekhar at all in 2019
used data about field observations
of the trail network
to test what objective
these trails might be trying to optimize
perhaps surprisingly they found that
ants form trails that approximately
minimize the number of nodes
and also they preferred nodes with
physical configuration
condensing to reinforcement by fermi
they have argued that as there is a
small probability of
exploration at each node minimizing the
number of nodes
actually reduces the opportunities for
ends to get lost
which is quite interesting
a very natural and interesting question
to ask here is
how do ants find such paths without any
central control
and with minimum computation resources
to understand this question we model and
trail formation
here is a broad overview of our one
in our model there is a directed graph
with a source known s
and a destination node d denoting the
nest and the food source
there is also a bi-directional flow of
ants on this directed graph
the forward flow enters through node s
and proceeds along the forward edges
provided by the directory
graph the backward flow enters through
the destination node d
and travels in the opposite direction
and slave foreign edges as they traverse
them
and the next h2 traverse is chosen based
on the level of pheromone
this parameter level on edges decays
with time as well
some fraction of flow is lost as it
passes through each node
and this models the laws of ansi due to
exploration
now let me describe our model in much
more detail and more formally
each edge u comma v in our directory
graph
has a phenomenal level associated with
it
the pheromone level on this edge at time
t plus 1
is given by the following expression it
is equal to the
sum of the pheromone level on the
same edge at time t plus the forward and
the backward flow of the edge at time t
and this whole summation is multiplied
by a decay factor
denoted by delta
now let me describe how the flow values
are computed
and let me start with the forward flow
values
the total forward flow at a vertex is
the sum of
incoming forward flows and this
summation
is multiplied by a leakage factor
this leakage factor captures
the loss of ends due to exploration
now the total forward flow at the vertex
is distributed on its outgoing edges
based on their pheromone levels
and the simplest rule is a linear
decision rule that
distributes the flow on its outgoing
edges
proportional to their pheromone levels
later in the talk we consider other
decision rules
the expressions for the backward flow
are exactly the same
but in the opposite direction
here is the final summary of our model
now to provide better intuition and
clarity
we illustrate our model to an example
consider the following directed graph on
five nodes
we assume that the leakage on all the
nodes except the source source
node s and the destination node d is
equal to half and the decay factor delta
is equal to two thirds
we also assume that one unit of flow
forward flow enters into node s
at extent step similarly one unit of
backward flow enters into node d
again at each time step we also assume
that each engine our directory graph has
some initial pheromone level
denoted by numbers in blue curve
the one unit of forward flattering the
node s gets distributed onto its
outgoing edges
based proportional to their
phenomenon values now note that
the top edge incident to node s has a
phenomenon and the remaining two edges
have a
thermal level half and half respectively
half fraction of the incoming flow
goes into the top edge and the remaining
one fourth and one fourth
amount of the flow enters the middle and
the bottom edge
similarly there are two edges incident
to dot d
and both have the firmware level one
respectively
the one unit of backward flow entering
through node
d gets distributed equally
on the two edges incidentally therefore
the new flow values on the edges are
half one fourth one fourth on the edges
incident two mode s
and half and half for the edges
incidentally
we denote the forward flow values in
green color and the backward flow values
in red color now given these
updated flow values
the new pheromone levels on the edges
are computed as follows now consider the
bottom edge
incident to rotate the firm
the new pheromone level of this
particular edge
is provided by the following expression
it's equal to
2 3 which corresponds to the decay
factor and the terms
the three terms in the bracket are as
follows
the blue term 1 denotes the old
pheromone
level on this on that edge the zero
term denotes the forward flow value on
that edge
and half denotes the backward flow value
on the edge
this expression evaluates to value one
let's consider another example
now consider the edge incident to the
topmost node
in our directory graph note that the
flow values are zero
and the old firmware level on this
primary value on this particular edge
was one
and this these three terms
get multiplied by a decay factor two
thirds therefore the new firmware
value on this particular edge is two
thousand
okay so we updated the flow values
and using these new for flow values we
updated our pheromone values of the
edges this corresponds to one time step
update in our model
now using these updated flow pheromone
levels
we again compute the new flow values
now for simplicity let's just consider
the flow value the flow values
on the edge incident to the topmost node
okay
observe that there is a half unit of
incoming flow
incoming flow into the topmost node
and since the leakage of this particular
node is half
and since there is just one outcoming
wedges
the half unit of flow gets multiplied by
the leakage factor
which corresponds to one four unit of
flow
it just enters through the one outgoing
flow
okay similarly you can compute the
forward flow values and the backward
flow values on all the remaining
edges using these new updated phenomena
levels on the edges okay once we compute
these new flow values
using these new flow values we compute
the new phenomenon
uh values on the edges okay
this corresponds to the second time step
forward similarly we can keep on
updating these values
the forward backward backward and this
paragraph levels on the edges
okay
now we studied our model so far
let me describe some of the related work
our model builds on the work of
chandrasekhar gordon
and amlaka where they studied how hands
met in trail networks
and how they find alternative parts in
case of broken links
our work is different from traditional
and calling optimization
where they provide heuristics to solve
many complex combinatorial optimization
problems
in many cases the algorithms
there are pretty complex and might not
be biologically feasible
our work also resembles reinforced
random walk
introduced by diagonals back in 1988.
in a reinforced random walk there is a
graph and an agent at a particular at a
start node
an agent picks the next edge to traverse
based on the edge weights
on all the incident edges to that
particular node
now when the agent takes a particular
edge it updates the edge weight
by some additive value 1
and the agent keeps on traversing in the
graph
this is called as the reinforced random
one and our model
differs from this reinforced random walk
in several key places
for instance in a reinforced random
there is a single agent that travels
through the whole graph
while in our cases we have many ads
traversing the graph modeled by this
flow for
modeled by this notion of flow
in our in our model we also have then
these edge weights
which we can also think of as the
fermion level on that particular edge
decays with time but in the case of
reinforced random work
it's fixed it doesn't decay with time it
gets updated
whenever an agent takes that particular
edge
also note that at each particular vertex
we also have a leakage factor
associated with that particular node
which is upset in the reinforced random
world
okay nevertheless the model we
propose and study is a marker process
that is relevant to biology
despite our model being so simple
understanding its behavior is highly
non-trivial
and our goal is to provide this process
and try to understand its behavior
in our work we try we prove some
convergence properties
of our model in the case of simple
graphs
and in in simulations we observe that
these results also hold for much general
class
in the remainder of the talk shivam will
describe some of these main results of
our work
and we'll finally formally state some of
these some of the open questions
that came out of homework thanks kiran
i'm shivam and i'll describe our results
our first result is for the case when
the incoming forward and backward flows
do not change with time we show that for
graphs consisting of two parallel paths
let's say p1 and p2 from s to d
where p1 is the path with minimum
leakage
if the incoming forward and backward
flows do not change with time
and the initial pheromone level at all
edges on p1 is positive
then the flow dynamics governed by the
linear decision rule
converge to the path p1 that is
eventually all the flow will go through
the minimum leakage path
here by a leakage of a path p
we mean the fraction of flow that would
leak out while moving through p
now what happens for more general graphs
we ran simulations
on general graphs drawn from various
random graph families
and observed that the dynamics converged
to the minimum leakage path
in all of these simulations and our
conjecture is
that the result holds for general graphs
actually even for the seemingly simple
case
of two parallel paths the proof requires
careful construction of an appropriate
potential function
and i'll discuss more about this proof
towards the end
here is a simulation that illustrates
this result
in this graph you can see the forward
flow coming
from the source vertex s and the
backward flow from the vertex d
these vertices are represented by dots
of different sizes
the larger dots represent vertices with
smaller leakage
eventually we want that all the flow
goes through
the path containing the larger dots that
is the path with minimum leakage
so let's see what happens
so as expected eventually all the flow
goes through the path with minimum
leakage
okay observe that when all the vertices
have equal leakage
in this case the path with minimum
leakage is same as the path with minimum
number of nodes
so this gives a possible explanation for
how
turtle ants could find paths with
minimum number of nodes okay
so this was for the case when the
incoming forward and backward flows
do not change with time but what happens
when these flows do change with time
our next result is for that case
we show that for graphs consisting of
two parallel paths
let's say p1 and p2 from s2d where p1 is
the shorter path
if the initial pheromone level at all
edges on p1 is positive
there is no leakage that is leakage on
all the vertices is zero
and the incoming flow increases with
time
either linearly or exponentially
then the flow dynamics governed by the
linear decision rule converges to the
path p1
that is eventually all the flow will go
through the shortest path
here this rate of increase whether it is
linear or exponential
will determine the rate of convergence
again we conjecture that this result
holds for general graphs
and our simulations are consistent with
this conjecture
one way of interpreting this result is
that it is saying
at least in principle hands have the
ability
to obtain information about path length
by just varying their flow rates
in fact previous works have shown that
argentine ants
are capable of finding the shortest path
in certain simple graphs
from past works we also know the
detection of new food sources
can often positively reinforce the rate
of flow of ants
and our result is basically saying that
there might be a connection between
these two phenomena
and it would be really interesting to
explore experimentally
whether certain whether certain ad
species actually increase their flow
rates
to find paths with minimum length
or the shortest path so till now
we saw that the dynamics converge to
either the minimum leakage path
or the shortest path depending on
whether the flow is increasing or not
and whether there is leakage or not and
these results
are for the case when the decision rule
is linear
this this raises many questions how
important is the bidirectional nature of
flow for these results
how do the dynamics behave when the
decision rule is non-linear
next we will try to understand these
questions
we show that bi-directional flow is
indeed necessary
for all pheromone based rules to
guarantee convergence to the shortest
path
or the path with minimum leakage
note that this holds not just for the
linear decision rule
but for any rule that divides the that
divides the flow
just based on the pheromone levels
the idea behind this result is that
suppose there is only one way flow from
the source to the destination
and in this case consider the outgoing
edges from the source
these edges do not get any information
about the rest of the graph
so there is no way that the dynamics can
discover which of these edges lies on
the shortest path or the minimum leakage
path
okay next we'll try to understand how
the dynamics behave for non-linear
decision rules
for this we consider a very natural
family of decision rules that satisfy
certain requirements the first
requirement is that
the decision rule should divide the flow
among edges just based on their
normalized pheromone level
so the absolute value of the pheromone
levels should not matter
the second requirement is that the rule
should be continuous
in the sense that small change in
pheromone level
should not cause a sudden change in how
the
flow is divided by this rule
and the final requirement is that this
rule should be monotone
in the sense that when this rule is
dividing the flow between
two edges in this case increasing the
normalized pheromone level
at an edge should not decrease the
proportion of flow
entering this edge so this is a fairly
natural family of decision rules and
note that the linear decision rule
satisfy all these three requirements
and therefore it is part of this family
so our next set of results basically say
that
the linear decision rule is the
unique member of this family with
guaranteed convergence to the shortest
or the minimum leakage path
in particular consider a graph
consisting of two parallel paths
in the case when forward and backward
flows do not change with time
and for every non-linear decision rule
in this family
there exists a setting of leakage
parameters such that the dynamics do not
converge to the path with
minimum leakage similarly
when there is no leakage in that case
for every non-linear decision rule in
this family
there exists a setting where the
incoming forward and backward flows
increase exponentially
such that the dynamics do not converge
to the shortest path
so one way of interpreting these results
is to think of
leakage change in flow and non-linear
decision
rules as three forces preferring
different kinds of paths leakage prefers
paths with minimum leakage
increase in flow preference shortest
path and non-linear decision rules it
turns out
prefers certain paths depending on the
non-linear function
and how the initial pheromone levels
were
and our results are basically saying
that there could be conflict between
these three forces
now i'll discuss the proof ideas
i'll discuss the case of two parallel
paths
where the incoming flows are not
changing with time
in this case we want to show that the
dynamics eventually
converge to the path with minimum
leakage in particular we'll consider
this graph from s to d
where there are two parts p1 and p2 from
s2d
and path p1 is the path with minimum
leakage we want to show that eventually
all the pheromone will be on
this path here by s1 and s2
i denote the neighbors of vertexes
and by d1 and d2 i'll denote the
neighbors of vertex d
and what we want to show is that the
ratio of pheromone levels
at ss1 and ss2 and
at d1d and d 2 d go to infinity as t
goes to infinity
okay so as a first attempt at showing
this
maybe we can try to show that this ratio
itself
of pheromone level increases
monotonically
okay so so here i have just written the
pheromone level at time t plus one in
terms of the pheromone level at time
t the forward flow and the backward true
similarly for the other pheromone lip
okay so
now now this term
the backward flow at ss1 at time t note
that
i can replace it with the backward flow
at d1 d at t minus at time t minus
length of p1 plus 1
multiplied by the appropriate leakage
vector
and similarly for the other backward
flow term so this is what i have done
here
now from the linearity of decision rules
we can argue that this
ratio of forward flows is equal to the
ratio of pheromone levels at time t
and from this what we can conclude is
if we want to show that these ratio of
pheromone levels are increasing with
time
only these shaded terms really matter in
the sense that if these terms were not
there
this ratio would remain constant
as t increase okay
so in this shaded term we know that
the leakage of path p1 is smaller than
leakage of path q2
but it turns out we do not have a good
handle on these backward flow terms
in particular we would have liked if you
could relate these
backward flow terms with the
pheromone levels at ss1 and ss2 at time
t
but it's not very clear what's a good
way to do that
in fact it turns out that
the ratio of pheromone level this ratio
this does not increase monotonically
but if we consider the minimum of ratio
of pheromone levels across
last few time steps it turns out that
that that quantity increases
monotonically
so in particular if we consider the
following potential function
given by the minimum of ratio of
pheromone levels
at ss1 and ss2 and the ratio of
pheromone levels at d1 d and d2d
across the last l time steps where l is
the maximum of the length of the two
paths
we can show that this quantity increases
monotonically
i'll pause for a few seconds so that you
can absorb what this quantity is
okay so this is our potential function r
of t
and this is the ratio of pheromone level
that we
eventually want to argue that goes to
infinity
but note that even if we can argue that
r of t goes to infinity
that will imply that this ratio also
goes to infinity
so we'll just focus on proving that r of
t
increases monotonically
so just from the definition of r of t we
can argue that
this ratio of pheromone levels and the
ratio of forward flows
is at least as big as rt
and it turns out with a little bit of
algebraic manipulation we can show that
this ratio of backward flows is
also at least as big as rt combining
these two effects along with the fact
that
leakage at length pu leakage at path p1
is smaller than leakage at path p2 we
can show that
the ratio of pheromone levels at ss1 and
ss2 at time t
plus 1 is greater than r of t
similarly we can also show that the
ratio of pheromone levels at t1d
and d2d at time t plus 1 is greater than
r of t
and by combining these two facts we can
conclude that
r of t never decreases and strictly
increases
every l time steps to show that r of t
eventually goes to infinity we would
also
have to argue that this increase is
sufficient but i will not discuss it
here
so so the key step in this proof was to
basically come up with this potential
function
and after that showing that this
potential function increases
is not too difficult
it turns out that the proof for the case
when the flows are increasing with time
is very similar and uses the exact same
potential function
if you are interested in the proof of
that theorem or
any other proof i will encourage you to
go through our paper
this is all i wanted to cover as far as
the proof ideas are concerned
let me conclude now with the key
takeaways
so we gave a model for ant tail
formation that provides a possible
explanation for field observations in
particular how
turtle ants might be able to find paths
with minimum number of nodes or minimum
leakage
our results also suggest certain
interesting future experiments
in particular are there species of ants
that actually increase their flow rates
to find
short paths it would be really
fascinating to investigate that
as we discussed in the beginning these
results demonstrate how new algorithmic
insights
often emerge by investigating the unique
constraints faced by nature
the goal of this work was to
was to introduce this model and make a
first attempt at
understanding some of its properties
there's still
a lot left to be understood here in
particular may be the most
immediate open problem is to generalize
our
convergence result to general graphs
another interesting open problem
is to understand whether these results
can be generalized
to graphs with multiple source and
destination vertices
this would also be interesting from
biological perspective as the
trails that these ads form often have
often connect multiple
nests and food sources so it would be
really interesting to understand this
case
i think i'll end here thank you